okay hello everyone welcome to another
wolfram language design review
incremental language development and we
have a variety of topics today
starting off with system exception and
recursion limit
so
uh
i really don't like what dany has come
up with here i know what other people
think of this
i already approved it while you were not
here
right i mean the right the one
sort of disadvantage is that you
um
right since it's not throwing right the
only way to detect this is by scanning
for terminate
terminated evaluation so some things may
you know
uh well it hasn't been throwing it it
hasn't been
the current behavior
like this is just you get a message and
then it returns something
right
something it returns is you know
a um has the possibility of blowing up
on your face
so one question is maybe how how
first of all when would you ever try and
catch any of these things like if it
through a system exception
and wonder what circumstances would you
ever try and catch it
right so
so the the one situation where i
personally have tried to catch it is in
make boxes
and okay which you know i suppose i can
try to see if the result
right if the input was not terminated
evaluation and the result of make boxes
is terminated evaluation then i go and
replace that with
some other
i've got a different suggestion okay so
i claim what we really should have
is a wrapper
that's called i don't know
could be evaluation constrained
or could be
and
you know evaluation constrained
would
basically
uh
you know
would do something different if it hits
one of these limits and you could define
an evaluation constrained you could
define which limits you care about
um
and to me
okay so let's just take a look so first
of all i think we should typeset
terminated evaluation slightly
differently i think it should be more
obvious more pinky
so to speak that it's kind of a
a weird
you know
a weird
thing so to speak
comments from people
but i i really like what it's doing here
i mean in other words i've got a long
computation
something goes wrong
you know it cauterizes itself
and you know this is what we get
it should be failure q
probably so yes
well that's an interesting i mean this
is a well this is a jared ticket that i
think i've been assigned to me for like
a year or something like that but but
there's a i mean there was an idea a
long time ago about making basically um
i think it was either a second argument
to failure queue or some other
additional function that would sort of
let you have because right now failure q
basically just checks for like dollar
failed and underscore failure i think
um but the idea would be that you know
you could have a second argument or you
could tell it to look for missings and
you could tell it to look for
you know all sorts of other stuff like
that
don't we have a missing queue
we do yeah but but you might want some
it's not for example your queue is also
like dollar boarded and dollar cancelled
i think also give true
right but i mean there's sort of like
there are different classes of like you
know like for example confirm has a list
of things that it looks for
right but
you know right this should be in that
list i think that's what i'm well yes
right
from the start is the time to do it yeah
yes i agree with all of those statements
but
okay
let's talk about a couple of things here
so i i mean does anybody object to what
danny has implemented because i think
it's really good
the the only thing i wonder about is is
you know so this is presumably returning
back from the evaluator i wonder and i
haven't thought about this stan maybe
you have is maybe
maybe we could you know in addition to
the recursion limit could it have the
original
expression that was trying to be
evaluated
um so i've thought about that in a
called all complete or something yeah
it's possible it gets dangerous in part
because some of the known bugs go into
the formatting
and um i'm not sure that
people attach rules to format and stuff
like that that may be a different count
of worms that should be attacked
separately can i make a suggestion what
about turning it into an extract
how does an extract format
doesn't have like a data structure thing
right just as data structure of law
right
just like any other data structure
it'll be a summary right it's a summary
box with of data structure well okay
here's a different suggestion okay isn't
it the case that every one of these
terminated evaluations hangs off an
assignment
there is an assignment that caused it to
go bonkers
i'm not sure about that
i'm just not sure
okay
what do you mean an assignment do you
just like sequels or something that's a
left i i don't think so i think that
some some of them are just um
down values that don't involve
assignments no but then you can even
just imagine nest list or like nest
do you call nest of f comma x comma 10
billion
i think you get a dollar recursion on it
don't you
i hope so
oh well that's an even weird oh but
that's because the box yeah
the alighted box
it's blowing up
i mean it is nice i agree with rob it is
nice to be able to see some idea of what
what actually
you know i mean this is safety first so
to speak
but
it will be nice to be able to see
something
if it wasn't typeset in it and you could
just query it out would that
solve the formatting thing
right that's what i'm wondering about
well is there any safe formatting that
could be done
you know even if the formatting was bad
by the way you're clicking horribly
sorry i'm trying your example or a form
of it
okay
the
oh having recently dropped in i i now
know your actual keyboard configuration
oh
okay
crazy but that's all right
the yeah
does have a reverb doesn't it yes
um okay
uh
let's see
um but but i mean
to this point of that would be nice to
see some idea of what it was that blew
up
what could we safely show people
i don't really understand how does this
work the terminated evaluation thing
where does it where does it intercept
what's going on
uh same place that recursion limit has
always been intercepted uh there's a
function called too deep which gets
called in a handful of places in the
core evaluator routines
okay the the val loop okay what what
else does it know
um
well it
okay so it knows that it has exceeded
either recursion or number of valuations
it does not if i remember correctly know
the um
expression
well how does that how it caused it
but how does that come out in most cases
oh it it's basically saying yes we we
got too deep and
hold on just a sec let me look at the
code
well i mean right you catch it you you
still have right where you catch it you
still have the original expression yeah
and and also no i what i said is wrong
too deep is called with the expression
so
it had been wrapping hold
okay fine so now you're doing this and
blowing away the expression so if we
could give you a way to do something
safe
with that extra structure basically
right
yeah and
i mean so really what's needed i mean
you could if i'm if i'm not mistaken
with modern technology you could take
that expression e
and
treat it as an x struct is that a true
statement is there an easy way to turn
an in-memory
expression
into an expert struct you mean the extra
struct data structure yes
i think you can just call create data
structure on it but oh but it'll
probably be no but it's in it's in
internal yeah
right so the question is is there an
internal code version
that returns
a thing that is the purely
you know sort of completely notified
data structure
yeah rob
yeah i don't not that i can think of
plus
it seems to me like it shouldn't
well i know right it shouldn't be very
hard or should it i wouldn't have
thought it would be hard because it's
right to say it's the same we could do
it probably with an expert bag they're
they're fairly uh quite inert
well but okay i don't know if we want
that
yeah okay we probably could i mean see i
mean besides sort of talking about the
original idea i haven't i haven't played
with these expression data structures at
all
so
okay all right fine okay but let's
assume that we could turn it into an
extra struct object okay completely
inert
there's no possibility of of explosion
anymore
now the only question is can we format
it in any kind of reasonable way
and i would argue that having some
pretty printing capability for extra
struct isn't such a bad idea anyway
i think at least that the head for an
expression struck would be nice to be
able to just see oh and the depth and
things like this i mean we could make a
summary box basically and expert struct
does have a summary box just like all
data structures i mean i don't know why
we're talking about okay
well let's make that let's just say that
so we say create data structure
of
extra struct why isn't expert struct in
the
in the autocomplete
is there any reason the expert structure
is not in the autocomplete guys
is that the correct sure i think it is
extra structure but you should figure
out first before you
just try running you know
just give it like f or something yeah f
one two three
well i wasn't gonna run the real thing
though
x was so we made a mistake here so this
is like the fifth thing like this that i
found recently where the string
autocomplete wasn't updated
guys
so i'm just
who's nobody here is responsible for
that
[Music]
no i understand but i mean okay so i'm
just saying again
okay so it goes to user assistance and
let's make sure it gets done who is
project i'm saying i got that auto
complete in yesterday's build at least
on windows so i don't know if it was
just fixed recently
okay fine
i can send that over
okay all right
rather uninspiring
information about the expert struct
but yeah i mean that's
look
a slightly prettier version of that
where you know i'm sure we can take that
and say depth here
huh well whatever
um
[Music]
why is details okay another bug guys why
is there no preview for details here
why do you ask questions of people who
have no ability to answer them
you're not responsible for the
documentation build
right because i don't actually know
who's here and i'm also hoping that
whoever is project managing will
will and consider the question partially
rhetorical
okay
depending on who's here right
um okay
okay fine
um
i'm surprised there isn't a depth
thing here and arguably that should be
added can we can we suggest that also
please
that makes sense
avery did you get that
yes you get that yes yes
okay
okay so i mean if i do this and i say
head we'll certainly get that
but is it clear that we always want
depth here or
i don't know what we want i mean look
what we want
is a
you know if we can turn it into an extra
struct
then we can pick out certain things to
put in the summary box
safely because it's a it's a completely
inert object we just go walk it i no you
don't know that
i mean i suppose you could
you could you could return things like
length and depth but there's no part of
the expression that can be safely
extracted leaf count maybe would be
useful maybe yes but let me point out
no part can be returned as an expression
but if you have a symbol there you could
return a string version of the symbol
you could do all kinds of things like
that would just say
i had thought about stringifying also
but it seemed like that you can't but
you can't stringify the whole thing
because you need to go through a printer
you know through the form yeah
yeah yeah
also i think i think what makes sense is
if we can get it into an extra struct we
can then decide what we write as the
summary of the ex-prostruct
you see what i'm saying
well that's a question for expert
strength not for trump i know i i know
but i'm saying to you so okay sorry
here's my suggestion okay
my suggestion is number one there are a
few extra features that are probably
desirable for extra struct here
i mean i don't know what visualization
does there let's take a look
that's super dangerous
right so that's going to blow up
in the case of these deep things well is
that actually containing expression or
is that a string
i'm sure it's a string but i'm sure it
went through the formatter to get that
and that can blow up yeah right format
rules
i i will have a suggestion as the person
who kind of hijacked well definitely
hijacked the agenda to get this on it
um
i what what i think would be helpful is
to get the current
version
um if it's okay to get that into our
builds
so that we see what we see
yeah i think it's fine but
and we can yeah we can i'm i'm perfectly
fine with going and changing it yeah
avery can make a journey
several suggestions here okay
point one i think somebody and it could
be from i mean i don't know exactly
where this gets done
should try and make as a wfr should try
and make a thing that's a an extra
struct summarizer
remember making sense
you know you had no idea who would do
that
honestly what do you mean by summarizer
though you mean just make some some box
thing yes yes make some box thing that
tries to do something intelligent but
safely on an extra struct
like it says how many leaves it has it
says its depth it says its overall head
you know maybe it says what symbols it
has in it i don't know but you know just
tries to make some kind of convenient
thing that could be put in a box
so okay maybe a
naive question what is the advantage of
using extra struct for any of this as
opposed to just like a hold complete
it doesn't format
yeah that's the problem you can't format
it as soon as you get inside the whole
complete to 400 it close itself up
i mean this is a deeply unsafe object
i mean but then maybe we can just have
an another symbol with attribute hold
all complete
that doesn't format or maybe it oh well
can't the formatting just
own be owned by the uh
the terminated evaluation just don't
display the second thing just show you
know dot dot dot or whatever
well right but okay i'm simply
suggesting the mechanics of how we do
this that for the sake of our code
you know if we can return it into
terminated evaluation
whatever as an expert struct and then we
call some formatter on it
then potentially it might be useful to
get out the extra struct form if you
want to do debugging if you really want
to know what's in there the extra
structure is a nice safe thing that you
can do as an advanced debugger you can
you can actually use
but then to have the default
version of what happens
be some safe pretty printing of an extra
struct which will be a useful thing to
have anyway
and making sense i mean to have a pretty
printer for export structure and right
now visualization is a naive pretty
printer that i'm sure just throws it
into the formatter
but it's a it's a safe
you know safe display
which could be you know we could succeed
in giving the first few levels i don't
know i mean if the safe display is
carefully written it could go a fixed
number of levels down it could produce
input form of things you know
it could do all the right things
i mean producing something that looks
like
you know this thing at the top here will
be magnificent
or something you know a bit like that
with a with a you know that will be
magnificent but we don't want to do it
unless it's completely safe to do it
does this make sense
yeah and i think we could we could set
up a depth and and length limit
um
or maybe a total limit that would that
fine yeah
i don't know enough about formatting to
really say much other than
it also has
deep recursion
crashes which have not
um all been thwarted by these changes so
i'm not sure we can make that so safe no
i i i that's that's substantial say it
again
you have an extra structure the extract
is a hundred percent inert okay just you
know it's as inert as a string or
anything else it has no ability to have
its pieces evaluate in the evaluator
unless you choose to pull them out and
feed them to the evaluator
okay my statement is don't do that
go straight to boxes
that are again themselves i hope inert
no that's not true i mean if you're
trying to format it
i mean you you can extract certain
properties and display those properties
like you can create a summary box but
you can't actually display contents
without that okay what i'm saying then
it is this i'm saying at the very least
create a summary box
okay
we may
it's a stupid summary it's a limited
summary bucks but that is a summary box
which one the one that says the
structure of
open bracket sure
sure sure but i think that
i don't think we should explicitly show
the data structure thing i think it
should be a summary box
that is you know a terminated evaluation
summary box
that
one one member of which
could be the aurora struct
okay so this becomes
a a box which is somehow pinked
and
it says i don't like this at all
which aspect of it the the
form attaching formatting rules to
terminated evaluation
right the whole point is we just got
into trouble by evaluating things i know
i know i'm telling you don't evaluate
anything terminated you can't run make
boxes without evaluating things i know
so i'm not saying i'm saying don't run
what you get back from terminated
evaluation is the string recursion limit
together with an expert a completely
inert extra struct object i understand
all that and i don't and i think that's
what the user should see
why
why it's really hostile i mean why is it
hostile it's exactly what they i know
but but look
we should improve the summary box of the
data of the expert struct
well i i think it should be a custom
summary box for the terminated
evaluation case of expert stock but you
know that's a minor issue
i i don't think we want all of the stuff
like like in the traditional in the
typical experstruct you really don't
care about safe visualization it doesn't
need to be safe there's nothing going to
blow up
but in this case we know it's going to
blow up so we have to do something
that's safe we have to make it not
a full visualization of the extra struct
we need it to be some kind of skeleton
visualization
of a nature we don't completely know but
we want to go
where we wherever we can go safely we
should go
so if we can get the first three levels
of heads safely as strings and things we
should do it if we can't then we don't i
don't know i haven't thought it through
but look i think from you know just
let's just i think we should get
terminated evaluation the first argument
is
um that recursion limit string or
whatever second argument is the extra
struct
and then
hopefully we can display that whole
thing as a summary box that is a
terminated evaluation summary box that
indicates that something went wrong it's
a it's a pink summary box of some kind
well then it's not a summary
okay fine fine then it says that it's a
modified summary box just like the fact
that a
zero you know
a zero precision number
you know a negative precision number is
a pinked thing
which i think is quite successful
because this is a something went very
wrong and it's a meaningless object kind
of story
if it's a meaningless object why are we
returning it
because it's useful for debugging
then it's not meaningless okay whatever
whatever nor is the negative precision
number meaningless
right i mean it's the same story it's
the same same type of thing i mean if i
say
zero back tick minus ten is that gonna
do the right thing
how do i get the how do i get the thing
that is is the pinked version
or is it plus ten anybody rob you must
know you can you can't do it with exact
zero
i i have a zero point there
uh
yeah it's i'm trying to remember exactly
how you get there
there
you know something a bit like that
graphically i would think
um nick is making the suggestion here in
this chat
of why don't we have a wrapper
called disable formatting we do have one
what is it
it's it's a little hack to try to
disable formatting that's used in some
places but you know it doesn't actually
right it's still you still go through
all of make boxes so
uh
so you think it's not safe you think
there isn't a way to do disabled
formatting the same
um i'm not convinced
i think it's worth looking at because it
might be an easy thing to do here but i
think but i think also but i don't think
we want this in any event right because
these expressions are typically quite
well i guess if
um well i guess it depends on what our
starting point is right but if it's a
large expression then right it's going
to blow up in our faces no matter what
wait a minute there seems to be an
actual symbol called disable formatting
yes that's what i just said oh god i
didn't know that i've never never heard
of it yes you do
i guess you did because i'm sure i heard
of it yeah but i don't remember it
give sex
wow okay well look okay let's let's not
spend more time in this meeting on this
i think the path
you know we have
a couple of parts we have the extra
struct path
maybe we have a different path for
disabled formatting personally i think
expert structure is safer i think it's a
better idea because i think that for the
advanced debugger you know having being
able to get the extra struct of the
incendiary you know of the explosive
expression is a good thing
that makes sense
um okay so okay so dan i think we have a
path forward here yes
yeah um i would still
like to see what we have to go in for
the interim
um like i say a ticket can be made i'm
going to be away for three weeks
and i can start on it right after i get
back okay well put this in
put in what you have try and figure out
how to get the extra struct thing in
there yeah no i'll look at that i think
i think it's viable okay fine and then
then independently somebody should try
and write a safe formatting up for extra
structs for wfr
and if nobody in this meeting can do it
i think we can think that we can find
other people in the ild orbit who can do
it
um
well it'll take a little bit because i
mean
you know i think the expert needs to
have some some properties added to it
like death
fine i mean that that's i i think that
you should try doing something where
you're literally peeling off the
expression layer by layer
and yes it needs depth added to it but
then you can peel off a couple of layers
and um
you know and potentially show those with
strings or what how do you want i don't
know we're not solving that problem
right now
okay okay meanwhile there's one more
thing which is i think we should have
this thing
called something like evaluation
constrained
that allows one
to
basically catch these things to i mean
yes it's the equivalent of saying block
dollar recursion limit equals whatever
but
it seems more elegant to have something
like that comments from people
well it would be different right i think
because we would want it to
not right we would want it to not catch
the exception so that the user can catch
it
um
in which case i'm not sure that
constraint is the right word
uh
sorry so what are you saying
right you suggested the evaluation
constrained as a response to my point
that
well if
if you're having the evaluator catch the
exception and replace it with
this terminated evaluation
so
it's um
well what i was thinking is
if what you want to do is to have a
catcher you can put in you can wrap you
i mean what is the use case the use case
is if something went wrong deep inside
there i want to blow out rather than
having
the um you know rather than thinking i
got the right answer but in fact there's
a terminated evaluation somewhere deep
inside
right and i claim that can be achieved
by saying evaluation constrained
and that evaluation constrained if
something goes wrong
um
is you know will then blow out
yeah i think that can be done by setting
you you construct this
dan's expression and then
immediately on construction of that you
you throw in a board
yes that in a board just like just like
memory constraint sits in a board
we actually are throwing um using the
internal throw now
which has the effect of setting um the
abort mechanism yeah
uh
triggering it i should say but we also
internally catch this thing which
untriggers
right so with this with this wrapper we
just wouldn't wouldn't wouldn't catch it
or we'd change it to something else
right
will this wrapper itself catch it or not
yeah the wrapper itself would the
wrapper itself would basically catch it
and what it would do is it would say
uh
you know evaluation constrained
and then it would be exper and then then
there will be the fail expert here and
then there might be some things where we
say recursion limit
i don't know how we do this we might
probably have something like recursion
limit arrow blah iteration limit error
blah and so on
nick you can you can you can speak
you've written a long essay here
um
just a comment about
extract and in my confusion how will you
actually store the inert expression
inside of it
if you already have something but they
don't want to
evaluate it
sorry say that again you have to wrap it
and hold and then extract it
yeah i mean i think that otherwise
create data structure would have to be
made a whole rest function
oh you mean
lots of data structures yes
right but an evaluated wrapper
why wouldn't it work
i think it should work that maybe should
work yeah
if it doesn't it should
splatter get rid of the part
yeah that's wrong
that should work right there that was an
extra structure three probably yes well
i think that doesn't work because
create data structure is
you know is is
um wolfram language code is supposed to
be none in c code and so at the end of
that i mean things end up getting
evaluated multiple times
you know it should be possible to make
it work even in wolfram language but the
question is how much effort is it and is
it justified right
so as somebody who regularly does such
things because that's the only game in
town and make but make boxes world i
know it is possible it's just a pain
all right okay yeah okay nothing more to
say about this i mean so we've got
okay so we've got so dan is going to
look at terminated evaluation and
evaluation
well we have that now
i know we just went through what we need
to do to enhance it right
yes wait a sec this evaluation
constrained
that's the part i'm i'm balking a little
bit on i didn't realize that that was
i thought that this was a separate bit
of new functionality
it is i'm just suggesting that given
that you're going to do terminated
evaluation that we could consider adding
this at the same time since this no
no we cannot consider adding it at the
same time this is not a small
new project and it's really
um
in a sense orthogonal
not really not entirely because could
you discuss it offline then okay
you know if it turns out it's super hard
and but i don't think you know let me
back back up one step adding the um
extra struct
might not be
insanely difficult
to get that into the terminated
evaluation expression good
adding evaluation constrained as a new
function is a different matter entirely
okay why don't you think about it
because i don't think it doesn't seem
like it should be that hard but i you
know i don't think we can figure that
out instantly we need to move on please
okay
okay so make sure to another meeting bye
thanks ej
okay
um sub matrix replace
okay so now what isn't this
is this brad's thing and so is brad here
yes yes i'm here
i mean if we just want to pick up the
discussion from yesterday
remember we were talking about um
possible multi-way evaluations that
aren't confluent
yes i think that this comparison here
with sequence replace it gives an
example of that
okay so hold on a second so
sequence replace
what the heck is sequence replace
okay we've got this issue with string
replace with with pattern matching in
general of what happens when there's an
overlap
you know like for example with string
replace we have this mechanism
right of saying string replace
of let's say
a b b a
no just aaa
arrow a a goes to x
string replace list maybe
and then we say overlaps goes to true if
i'm not mistaken oh it doesn't have an
overlaps
i thought it had i thought string
replace had an overlaps
anybody know what i'm talking about here
maybe just assumes
our apps always true
i think you may be thinking of string
cases
maybe i am well let's look at what
overlaps i'm not totally sure what
string or place would do if there was an
overlap
yeah you're right but string replace
list could deal with overlaps
yeah just a simple place
it's always true
oh it's always
true
okay so string cases it might be true or
it might not be true
so in this case here
okay whereas with overlaps to false
it used up the aaa and so it can't give
the aaa the other a
so is that the first a a or the second a
a
that's the first a a
because it used up that middle a a
middle a
and so it couldn't use it so it couldn't
so it no longer matched
so it reads left to right
yes
which i believe is what string replace
does as well
one two
three
yeah it's what string replace is doing
sequence replace sorry it's doing as
well
okay so what's the is there there's a
sequence cases right
if i do sequence cases of this
huh
maybe i need to say
alternatives
yeah
okay
fine
so now does this have an overlaps
yes it does
okay all right so that's how that works
now
surely okay but sequence replaced list
does sequence replace list exist
sequence replace list no why doesn't
that exist
am i confused here and isn't sequence
replaced list kind of quintessential
uh you know what we're doing in
multi-way systems thing isn't that
correct
what would be a difference between
sequence replace and just a replace with
some sequence patterns
it's just more efficient right i think i
think so it's easier to set up
that's it
um
as opposed to subset replace
which can pick the variables up from
anywhere
right subset replace
here if i say one two three and then i
say three one goes to
x then i get that
right
now
both of these both sequence replace and
subset replace could have a list version
as well
that does all possibilities
does that make sense
yeah yes
and that seems worth having i mean it's
at least in that corner but now
so
i just placed in the chart the list of
functions that have overlaps
assumptions
okay
okay
all right
so let's talk about sub matrix replace
what is sub matrix replace
it's the generalization of sequence
replace
to multi-level lists is that true
kind of but
the
sequence replace
it doesn't need to be strict about the
replacement rules
having the same length
but if you try to
you know
mess around with the lengths on the
replacement rules yeah i understand it's
not going to fit it's a tile that
doesn't fit yeah yeah
so what's the relationship between
sub-matrix replace and substitution
system
well this a substitution system will
basically can grow something
but in this you can also just replace
content
and if i say substitution system
i mean i'm not sure that this is the
right thing but i mean if i say this
and then i say that thing
comma
uh
that's weird that looks like a bug
that looks like it a bug where it should
take the non-listed
woo
maybe you have the arguments backwards
oh maybe i do yo
good point i absolutely do
there you go
i'm not mistaken that because the same
it's not the same it doesn't look the
same to me
first row is different
what did it do i mean i think it had a
different way i don't think it did
anything
oh it's an idea it's still an identity
matrix
why didn't it do anything
well okay but but you see that you see
why i would think it might do something
maybe oh i see maybe substitution system
can only work on single symbols there
you're right it it doesn't do this that
will be some kind of okay so why isn't
this um block
okay there's a there's a family of
things called things like block map
so would this be
the analog of block map for replacement
well i i think when we were doing this
we had used block in the language but
then because block itself
was some other function we decided to
change away from that
okay but block map we've already crossed
that bridge so the question is
what does this so if you said
block replace
so
the concept here is
this is something which just like block
map
if we say
you know
block map f comma
um
this thing here comma two
now i really want to say two two here
well should you change that for an
identity matrix first
i don't matter i'm just
that that is an identity matrix
well it's got doesn't have some
formatting on it no
no i don't think so
it looks like matrix form but it isn't
because the matrix form is stripped on
copy like that anyway okay so there it
is so that is
the block
you know that is applying f to two by
two blocks
correct yeah but now
um
is there a way to do the overlaps
because
it's missed some of the overlaps i think
well here you say comma one right
and then it'll do the overlaps
yeah but now the matrix has changed size
because it had its overlaps changed
because it had an f applied to the
overlap so i this isn't the same as
block replace okay it's similar
but it's similar that's the point
so
what this block replace might do
is to say which is essentially yours
your sub matrix replace
it would take the thing
i mean i don't see why it isn't just
block replace
of
the
array
and then the sub array arrow another sub
array
and if the sub array sizes don't match
in here then just doesn't do the
replacement
does this make sense and i mean there's
also a case where
you might do it at a particular position
but i think if you were going to do that
i mean because there's no way to do
replace part like this
well okay then what about the collisions
wait wait a second look we have subset
map but subset map doesn't care about
ordering
yes but it's able to extract a few
objects and reinsert
another collection of the same length
yes but they don't have to be
you know uh they don't have to be
adjacent objects
right right
whereas this the idea would be
that this is
taking
a matrix
and transforming blocks of the matrix
now i don't quite understand
why this isn't just
block map
of
replace
hash comma rule
on the original array
actually it doesn't even need to be that
just could say replace like this
couldn't it
did you see what i'm saying
the only thing we don't get there is the
automatic sizing of that stride there
which we would get in the sub-array on
the left-hand side
does that make sense
hello
i mean can we try an example if it's
really that easy
yeah we could try your example here
let's do this one here
this has multiple rules right
yeah
what's that doing there
that's not going to work it can only be
one size
well to work with block map it can only
be one size
okay
right because it's because it's
pre-breaking it
then it's doing it
yeah sub matrix replace
no i understand i understand so it does
something slightly different because
it's using
the sizes
from
the um
oops so now we have to say two two
like that
great
or whatever
okay i i don't know why i did that but i
mean again
well it's not funny offsets then
we can ask it to find offsets but but
this is still everyone
together it's gonna be wrong
yeah it's not stitching correctly
right because block map
is just doing the replacement it's not
doing the restitching right if you
ignore the offsets it could stitch back
but if you don't then it can't in
blackmail yeah there needs to be an
array flatten here
to restitch it
am i making sense
guys you're very very silent yes that
makes that that makes sense but i mean i
i think that the
submatrix replaced makes sense as a
standalone thing fine i i don't know if
this is definitely it should be called
block replace and that it
and we've got semantics for it okay
so if you guys could actually
okay
do you do you understand what i'm saying
i think this is right i think it is
similar to block map but not the same as
block map
but it should be block replace
and it should have the semantics we just
described
right
yeah i kind of wanted it to be called
block replace to start off with
fine okay and the rule is the left-hand
side and right inside the rules have to
be the same size that's correct now the
only thing that we're not giving here is
a replaced part where you're saying
where you want this to be done
that sounds like a different function
just like replace and replace part or
arguably yes yeah but also um
there is a collision function with
submatrix replaced because once you
start
looking at all the possible overlapping
blocks
we'll see that overlaps problem
okay all right so that's a different
issue right what happens
if
what happens in the case of collisions
right how do we resolve collisions
and
do you have a proposal for how to do
that
well yeah at the time that we had scoped
out some sort of collision function that
was based on
you know what the various values are
what the previous value is and
also maybe even location in the matrix
oh yeah fine so the question is do we
want to have and we could have block
replace
just doing the default left to right top
to bottom scan
right
but what you're saying and it relates a
lot to this graph scanning thing etc etc
etc what is the relationship between
collision function
and
you know
and this traversal order business that
we talked about
well i think essentially the collision
function
can just be a choice of ordering indeed
or it could be something different or it
could average them or something like
that
yeah yeah i guess so right
replace has the same issue if you're
using like pattern sequence right and
yes
yeah well i mean if we figure out
um something nice to do with the
collision function here
i think that we could expand it to other
situations where we i agree i agree so
let's discuss okay look we've got two
different related things we've got
traversal orders which are you know
first
thing gets it type collision functions
and the second is you've got a bucket of
things that are all where you have to
because that efficiency wise you know by
the time you are enumerating all the
possible collisions
okay
that's
lots of stuff
no i don't know in this case maybe not
yes in general it's true it might not be
true in this case but in general it's
true so there are two different things
you might want you might want a
traversal order where the first reached
wins where you don't have to look at the
replace list analog thing and another is
the case where you want to look at the
whole replaced list and then
do some combination of those things yeah
that makes sense to people yeah i think
that the traversal order thing is just
like the deep default behavior
of say sequence replace
with the right i know i know i know i
know but i'm saying that's not the only
possible traversal order nick do you
have any comments about this or anybody
else have comments i mean to me it seems
like we should support in these
functions that have collisions we should
consider supporting a traversal order
option
yeah
okay because that would be one collision
avoidance so then there's there's you
know what we could do is to have a
traversal order and we can have
a so
we've really got two different branches
here we've got the single way evaluation
or single way traversal and we've got
multi-way traversal in multi-way
traversal it makes sense to do a take
all the multi-way branches
and have an observer so to speak that
samples all those branches and makes the
decision about what to put in that slot
that's one case
the other case is it's single way and
whoever gets their first wins
comments nick christopher anybody else
yeah it's two totally different things
but if the collision do you have a
comment on this please
nickelodeon again
oh that's a good question
i don't have a strong opinion on the
multi-way case that's probably a nick m
question but i do think that for the
single way a traverse order solves the
problem of dealing with collisions for
sure
right
neck m and for the multi-way case
it's kind of
i don't know the the one thing that can
solve it
that
when you're doing a replacement there's
kind of two ways you can go afterwards
so you can either go breakfast or that
first right and it can be a part of an
actual state
okay it's like what state can you get
can tell you where where to go next
and i don't think it whether it makes
sense not
say that again what
it's a it's this
dualism where do you
whether you have an overlap whether you
look at it like you have a two separate
events that produces two separate
universes that you can branch in
universe that you can export
separately or you actually produce some
superposition state
yes
and and this would be like going just
creating a state
locally changing it
well well sorta does create a
superposition but then once it creates
the superposition
it looks through the there's a decision
function that looks through the
superposition and says which actual
value it wants
if it is one value which will you
probably better get with the traversal
order or more likely in the
superposition state
you know just like in look in quantum
mechanics for example it's like either
something you know either you're in the
world and something definite happens or
you want the probability vector for
example
right both of which might be a
reasonable thing to get out of the
superposition
does that make sense
well okay if you're trying to
say this matrix is an integer valued
matrix
and you're at one particular ij location
in the matrix a collision happens and it
stacks up
six particular energies i know so so
then you you want an integer out if you
want an integer matrix but you also
might want the average out yeah which
would be a non-integer
so you don't know so i mean i think
that's the if your collision function
says take the average
then you know obviously you're not going
to get an integer necessary can it do
that
why not
well i i don't know let's look at the
documentation and see if it can actually
work already for what
for for what's been implemented so far
oh for submitters i have no idea but but
yeah because it already has a lot of
functionality to it okay all right okay
well let's take a look but we're running
out of time it might be able to do mean
okay but i think it's a useful way to
think about this
but how do we get okay
yeah so right now the collision function
is saying it takes first of number two
i bet if you change that to mean of
number two yeah it will do the right
thing yeah
okay so i mean okay fine okay
we have to wrap up yeah but but um
i think the the main conclusion here is
we've got an interesting story of
collisions
the single way traversal order story
or the multi-way superposition type
story
and i think we probably i mean this is
you know okay what's basically happening
here is that now that we sort of
understand multi-wayism
we're seeing
you know signs of it all over the place
and i think we need kind of a a
consistent principled approach to this
stuff
where
um
so you know
in pattern matching so nick can you say
something about the pattern matching
case
i mean you've now got this thing that
that can enumerate all possible matches
yeah and the way i did it now a little
bit incorrect but whatever
it will ideally will do exactly the same
thing
there each pattern matching produces an
object that tells you where to go
whether you
should create a super position or just
go
like bread first for a
next match that you want to go
right
so something like that
it's like it should be a generator that
each of the party matching tells you
it's like you wanna get any results from
it and each result tells you which the
appropriate direction you should follow
in order to
get it
either it's an alternative you go
breadth first
or
it's a some kind of
sequence and you should go depth first
in order to get a single result
yeah i understand i mean i'm not sure
that that's okay this requires more
thought and a different
separate meeting um
and uh i have to go here
um
and i think why was this scheduled oh i
think we were late starting this meeting
um
oh and it was
scheduled
to be right up next to another live
stream i'm supposed to be doing that was
not so smart
uh
okay well
um
all right
so let's come back please and talk about
collision functions traversal orders
i think that's a general thing for all
of these overlap related functions
and um
is this easy this one here or is this
it's pretty easy um we basically had
this requested a few times and there's a
wolfram function repository version of
it
if we want to have a random date
function the question is basically do we
want to call it random date or random
date object
and then there's a random date
mm-hmm yeah
some random time min max
times
seems
right to me
okay yeah there's some minor questions
like what the default range should be
the random date to give you
a random instant within the current day
is kind of my preferred method
i think random date should do that
random time should do that random date
my god i don't know
time is infinite perhaps
right i'm tired between now
sometime in human history i don't know
right i mean random real doesn't give
you a random
integer on the number plane and it gives
you something between zero and one so
what does random complex do
[Music]
yeah
between zero and one as well with an
imaginary and real part
um
well anybody else got an idea here we
have a couple other arbitrary zero times
like if you do date object of zero it's
1900.
yeah i understand um that was invented
during the last century
um
okay
well anybody else i don't know i'd say a
random
random moment in the current year would
be would
be pretty i think the two candidates are
either within the current day or within
the current year okay so why don't we
plan on that random random date within
the current year random time within the
current day
okay
i have to run see you guys soon